you know it's been thought of that our
brains do not regenerate our brain cells
are not renewed okay this is a
completely false information because the
brain cell can regenerate in fact it's
the rate at which your brain cells
regenerate that determines how your
cognitive functions going to work or not
work as you get older So today we're
going to talk about how to actually
increase
this regeneration of your nerve cells by
a factor of 5x okay now yes this
research was done in animals and there's
also a lot of research done in humans as
well so as I go through the list I want
to cover a lot of different things that
you can do to increase the size of your
brain and you don't have to do all of
them you just need to pick as many as
you can do and if you wouldn't mind go
ahead and add those to the comments of
those things that you feel that you can
add to your current lifestyle to
increase the size of your brain or at
least the Regeneration of your neurons
because this list could be a little bit
overwhelming to some people you know you
can't do everything but you just do what
you can something is better than nothing
and the general term for a nerve
regenerating is called neurogenesis a
lot of This research is done on a part
of the brain called the hippocampus the
hippocampus well they don't know exactly
but it's involved in the relay of
information that's connected to memory
learning spatial navigation remember
layouts of certain things problem
solving which you kind of need your
memory for problem solving reasoning and
something else called object in place
memory that's like remembering certain
objects in certain environments like
where did I put my keys Etc now realize
this just because you don't remember
where you put your keys does not mean
you have a problem with your brain it
could be that you just ate poorly the
day before it could be that your blood
sugars are not quite correct if your
spouse a family member or your parent or
whatever starts having memory problems
the worst thing you can do is to remind
them of that and point that out because
it's almost like the more that you
remind someone like you know are you
losing your memory uh the more they
start losing their memory and even when
I was in practice I would notice this
with married couples that would be
coming in sometimes the spouse would be
correcting them if they you know said
something wrong or pronounce something
wrong or forgot something and I pulled
it aside and I just said you know what
if they do that again just kind of
ignore it okay
and I followed up with them and I found
that the person stopped making these
mistakes when the person stopped
reminding them that they were making
these mistakes so I think what happens
if you hyper focus on something it
actually sometimes could make it worse
one thing that's really interesting
about the brain okay is that
if we take a look at the size of the
brain and how much it weighs and we
compare that to the rest of the body it
only really makes up like two percent of
the whole body weight yet it requires 20
percent of the oxygen of the body
20 of the metabolism of the body is
given to the brain so it's an energy
Hawk and this is why this first thing
I'm going to tell you is so important
out of all the things you can do to
increase the size of the brain and
prevent atrophy is regular consistent
exercise and the type of exercise that
would be best is aerobic exercise and
what I mean is getting a lot of oxygen
now this is not to say that other types
of exercise is is not also really good
but if you can also include long walks
for example or some type of exercise
where you can get a lot of oxygen that
would be even better than other types of
exercise but I personally like to mix it
up I do high intensity on certain days I
might do hiking or long walks on other
days that is the most important
thing you can do to enhance
your brain regular exercise on the
opposite would be inactivity right not
exercising being inside all day that
would not be good for your brain the
second most important thing for your
brain would be
fasting and I'm going to say just like
intermittent fasting but also a periodic
prolonged fasting very potent stimulator
of certain factors that help grow your
brain and repair the brain function so
you need to be doing two meals a day
with maybe a fasting period of at least
16 17 18 hours okay that would be ideal
but if you can do longer like a one meal
a day and and fast for 23 hours that
would be even better
and this would all depend on your
lifestyle and also how much repair that
you need to do on the brain because
maybe you have some other issues like
but the point is that when you eat too
frequently and have these snacks which
is just a killer for a lot of problems
the brain suffers the most okay so this
idea that you have to constantly fuel
the body of the brain is false
information it does very well when you
don't eat so frequently and then
periodic prolonged fast for like maybe
48 Hours the next thing cold therapy
very potent stimulator of neurogenesis
which is the regrowing of your nerve
cells
so that could be an ice bath that could
be in just taking a cold shower some of
you are not going to do this but some of
you will do it but it definitely will
stimulate the Regeneration of brain now
if you combine all three of these you
can look way back in time when we were
always Starving in the cold and we're
constantly exercising to run and chase
animals to eat them and so our DNA has
been developed off that has adapted off
those three things to survive better
because we needed
our brains sharp so if you're out in the
cold and you're exercising and you're
not eating you can really support your
brain versus always being in a very
comfortable environment being around
food all the time like having a
refrigerator and just sitting back and
being inactive other things you can do
omega-3 very very potent stimulator of
growing your brain that would be like
cod liver oil why because a good portion
of the brain is composed of something
called DHA which is a type of omega-3
fatty acid okay so that would help you
greatly and it's very easy to do to have
some fish oils or cod liver oil that you
consume on a regular basis
now on the flip side of that the other
oil that's really bad for the brain is
oxidized oil like in the oils that are
heated like vegetable oils to create
those oils you have to heat them up with
solvents like hexane and then you use
them in heat too right you actually use
them to fry something or cook something
or deep fry something very very bad for
your brain of course recently we've
substituted those for the saturated fats
being the coconut oil the lard the
butter are actually very very good to
cook things in they're very stable as
long as you keep your carbs low
and so that relates to the next point a
low carb diet because sugar and refined
carbs and just eating a high carb diet
creates a lot of oxidation to the brain
and the Hallmark of neurodegeneration is
glucose hypo metabolism where glucose is
not being able to be metabolized in the
neurons okay that's the Hallmark that
occurs within the nerve cells which
means the destruction of the nerve cell
occurs because it's not getting glucose
fuel so does that mean you need to eat
more glucose no it means that you
already ate too much glucose and you
created insulin resistance and now you
basically create this resistance for
glucose as well and that's what destroys
it you basically starve off the nerve of
energy how can we use that information
we can lower the amount of glucose that
you eat and we can feed your neurons
a much better fuel which is ketones so
ketones are the fuel that can bypass
this damage of glucose and go right in
and feed the neurons directly so how do
we do that well we just lower our carbs
and our bodies will naturally generate
ketones we can also take ketones as a
supplement we can fast and generate
ketones do fasting intermittent fasting
we can also consume MCT oil because
you're going to generate more ketones
now I've mentioned cold therapy but you
also can do heat therapy which like in a
sauna or a hot shower that can also be
beneficial but not as beneficial as the
cold therapy I'm sorry another thing
that's really beneficial to the brain is
vitamin B1 thiamine and the opposite to
that a thymine deficiency which is very
common is the worst zinc for the brain
okay when someone does not have enough
B1 you start developing this condition
called wernick key course cough syndrome
it's a condition where you're very
deficient in B1 and the neurons are
degenerating okay so you have all sorts
of problems in the brain and this
usually occurs because you're eating a
lot of refined carbohydrates or too much
sugar and so when you don't have enough
B1 you actually get inflammation in your
brain and B1 is uh connected to so many
positive things for our bodies but
especially for the brain and also to get
rid of stress all right the next one is
probiotics which is interesting because
there is a connection between your gut
and your brain right I mean the microbes
in your gut make all sorts of the
serotonin and other neurotransmitters
and other factors so if there's a
problem in your gut there's a problem up
here in fact one of the side effects of
taking an antibiotic is problems with
your brain mood cognition and even
potentially certain types of dementia
which is interesting so if you just
support your gut you actually can help
this regeneration of your brain cells so
that would be consuming like foods that
have friendly microbes probiotics
sauerkraut fermented food
certain vegetables that are grown on
soils that have microbes and also that
fiber in the vegetables can actually
feed the microbes if you have many
different types of vegetables or
different types of lettuce leaves that
would be better because it's going to
create a more Diversified microbiome but
also there's another antibiotic or at
least something that was patented as an
antibiotic and that is glyphosate that's
the chemical in the GMO so that can
actually alter our gut microbiome
another reason why you should have
organic type foods now another thing
that can actually support your brain is
the sun you're going to get a type of
energy called infrared from the sun over
50 percent of the sun's Rays is infrared
and it can penetrate through your skull
okay and actually that can increase your
melatonin which can act as an
antioxidant to support your brain but
that's interesting and then also you
have the vitamin D from the Sun that can
also help the brain versus being indoors
to all sorts of artificial lights that
do not help your brain at all and then
there's also plant-based phytonutrients
that are really good for your brain
curcitin turmeric B phytonutrients in
green tea I mean there's just so many
different autonutrients in so many
plants that can help you then we also
get foods high in choline okay choline
is kind of the raw material for
acetylcholine a really
common neurotransmitter in your brain
you need acetylcholine and that's made
out of choline so what foods are high in
choline well you have egg yolks okay you
also have organ Meats fish okay so all
of those are really important for your
brain and then we also have grass-fed
animal products right grass-fed versus
grain fed grass-fed are more
anti-inflammatory because of the omega-6
to three ratios you want those like one
to one so that's just another point that
you want to be aware of when you're
consuming animal products there is a big
difference and then we get to its
sufficient sleep not just the number of
hours of sleep but the quality of sleep
that you get okay is very very important
if you have an insomnia and you're
living on caffeine and stimulants it's
going to start to affect the
Regeneration of nerve cells now what
about this topic of coffee well too much
caffeine can definitely create a problem
with your brain but if you have just a
small amount of coffee it's not going to
be a problem
especially since there's polyphenols in
the coffee that can support the brain
but excessive amounts of caffeine if you
drink too much can override that and
create a lot of problems because if you
think about it when you drink coffee it
does stimulate your cognitive function
right so over stimulation of that can be
damaging another really key nutrient for
the brain especially the hippocampus is
zinc okay zinc is involved in different
enzymes if you're deficient in zinc that
can create an atrophy of hippocampus and
affect your cognitive function as well
as your mood now since I mentioned this
topic of Omega-3 like the DHA oils which
is so important in brain health and it's
a real easy thing to implement I put
some more information up with this video
right here you should check it out